four types of Leverage that you can
employ in a business and this is
directly from Nal ricot the first level
is labor so you can get other people to
do work for you like you were doing
something someone else does it now you
don't have to do it that's leverage you
get more done for your time the second
level of Leverage is capital so that's
you asking for other people's money
other people spent their time to make
the money and then you use that money to
make money as well and you get a
percentage of that gain but you didn't
have to incur the cost of time to go get
the money third and fourth is code and
media code being software so if you
write something once people can use it
that's leverage you put one input and
you get infinite output media to the
same degree I'm recording this video
right now I record it once and a million
people can see it